[Müzik]
var düşüşünden tanıdığınız onca kişinin
hikayesini dinlediğinizi biliyorum ama
bugün ilk defa burada ayaktayken
gördüğünüz
düşüşüne tanıklık ettiğiniz ve
sonrasında çırpınışlarıyla kalkışını
gördüğünüz birinin konuşmasını
dinleyeceksiniz hoş geldiniz
[Alkış]
hikayemi kim olduğumu etiketlerimi
ınflu
yazarlığı mı anneliğimi Hepsini bir
kenara bırakarak geldim bugün buraya
Hatta siz değerli seyircilerin önünde şu
an sizi göremiyorum ama siz değerli
seyircilerimin önünde kadınlığımı da bir
kenara bıraktım Yani halk arasında
bildiğiniz o cv'imi her şeyi bir kenara
bırakarak geldim bir gün böyle bir
konuşma yapmak istediğimde bu şekilde
olacağımı hiç düşünmemiştim açıkçası O
yüzden bugün Kimliksiz birini
dinleyeceksiniz bir mecburiyetsizlik
haritası çıkardım kendime hayatımda
ve bunu anlatmak istiyorum size
hepinizin de bildiği gibi bilmiyorum ne
kadar takipçim var şu anda inanın
sizleri göremiyorum ama
hayatında saçıyla başıyla Hatta Coco
chanel'in de söylediği gibi
her gün bir Düşmanınla
karşılaşacakmışsın gibi giyin dediği
gibi her şeyiyle
hayatına devam eden bir kadınken var
olan her şeyini kaybetmiş bir kadın
olarak devam etmeye
çalıştım
34 yaşındayım bir çocuk annesiyim
Bütün bunlardan bağımsız Türkiye'de
yaşamaya çalışan etiketlerini bir kenara
bırakarak yaşamaya çalışan bir kadınım
ve bu mecburiyetsizlik haritasını
paylaşacağım sizinle birinci madde
olarak
önce hayatımda yaşadığım bütün üzüntülü
şeyleri Kabule geçmeyi öğrendim çünkü
Hayat insana her zaman az önce
jessica'nın da söylediği gibi Gül
Bahçeleri var etmiyor
ya da geçtiğimiz yollarda ezdiğimiz
çiçekleri her zaman bizim için
fark edilir hale getirmiyor Bu yüzden bu
mecburiyetsizlik haritasında ilk madde
olarak Kabule geçmeye karar verdim ve
hayatımda yaşadığım en büyük acıları
kabul et
ikinci madde olarak
güçlü olma konusunu birazcık daha farklı
bir hale getirdim kendimde ve dedim ki
güçlü olmak bir seçim değildir bir
zorunluluktur Çünkü herkesin kafasında
Aslında şöyle bir şey var başıma bir şey
gelirse ben ne kadar güçlü olabilirim
zaten başınıza bir şey geldiğinizde
böyle bir seçim hakkınız kalmıyor
Bir kere bunu düşündüğünüzde ve güçlü
olmanın Aslında içinizde ne kadar büyük
bir yer kapladığını öğrendiğinizde Bunun
bir seçim değil bir zorunluluk olduğunu
öğrendiğinizde gerçekten çok güçlü
durduğunuzu görüyorsunuz
3 madde olarak hayatımda
değiştiremeyeceğim her şeyi kabul etmeyi
ve değiştirebileceğim her şeyi
değiştirdikten sonra maksimum 48 saat
Üzülme kuralı koydum kendime
dedim ki ben eğer bir şey
değiştirebiliyorsam Okey değiştirilerek
hayatıma devam etmeliyim buralarda biraz
radikal kararlar verdim
kimliklerimden bağımsız konuşuyorum ama
şu an karşınızda hem Yalnız bir anneyim
hem hastalandıktan sonra boşanmış bir
Eski eşim Yani Türkiye'de en zorlanan
profilim ve tek başına ayakları üzerinde
durmaya çalışan bir kadın olarak dedim
ki değiştiremeyeceğin şeyleri değiştir
ve sonrasında yoluna böyle devam et
Diğerlerini de kabul et aynen başına
gelen kötü şeyleri kabul ettiğin gibi
içimdeki gücü farkettim artık Ayağa
kalkma zamanı dedim Bundan sonra kabul
ettiklerim var değiştirebildiklerim var
yapabildiklerim var yapamadıklarımı da
kabul etmek var ve sonrasında
ayağa kalkmaya karar veriyorum artık
tamamen ayağa kalkacağım
Bilmiyorum daha önce Duydunuz mu ama
saçın hafızası var
karşınızda Türkiye'de ve dünyada
saçını kaybetmiş bir kadın olarak Global
bir markanın bir şampuan markasının
marka yüzü var ben
2023'te Türkiye'den saçını kaşını
kirpiğini Hatta halk arasında geçirdiğim
rahatsızlıktan dolayı
kadınlığını da kaybetmiş bir kadın
olarak Global bir markanın marka yüzüğüm
saçımın hafızasında bundan sonra hiç
kötü onu biriktirmek istemiyorum
çok kötü yere çakıldım beraber tedavi
olduğum 23 kişiyi kaybettim aynı
koridorlarda tedavi gördüğüm ve
hepimizin aynı anda yeniden çocuklarıyla
kucaklaşacağına inandığım
Bu yüzden bu salondaki şu an göremediğim
herkesin bu salondan çıktıktan sonra
ayağa kalkmama lüksü olmadığını
düşünüyorum
bütün bu kimliklerimden bağımsız 34
yaşında Demet Özal olarak
Ayağa kalkma motivasyonumu Sadece
kendime dayanarak aldım Çünkü her şeyi
tek başıma kendi kendime yaşadım o
yüzden bugün burada olmaktan çok büyük
mutluluk ve gurur duyuyorum Umarım
Dinlediğiniz Bu hastalık ve yaşam
hikayesi ve en sonunda bitti zannettiğim
yıkıldı zannettiğim artık daha fazla
devam edemeyeceğim bir daha hiçbir zaman
saçlarımı savuramayacağım dediğim bu
hikayenin sonu sizin hayatlarınıza ilham
olur beni dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür
ederim buraya geldiğiniz için de çok
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
2019 yılında
hastalığımın en kötü döneminde bir
videom Var YouTube'da
çok kötü durumdayım artık Yürüyemiyorum
bana motivasyon olsun diye
arkadaşlarımla video çekiyoruz o dönem
pandemi de çok kötü durumda ben ekranın
bu tarafındayım onlar kendi evlerindeler
Çünkü Kimseyle görüşmem yasak ve o
çocukluk arkadaşlarımdan birinin bir
hayali var benimle ilgili bir gün
iyileşeceksin ve tekex konuşması
yapacaktık
beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür